chef José Andrés Muchísimas gracias por
estar con France 24 en este día en que
se cumple un año desde esta invasión a
escala máxima
del ordenada por el presidente Vladimir
Putin su organización hubo central que
quien ha estado dando de comer a los
ucranianos desde muy del comienzo de la
guerra Cuál es el balance de todo lo que
ha pasado y uno todo lo que ustedes han
logrado durante estos 365 días
simplemente va a emergencias y ayuda
pues con la comida y el agua
lo más rápido que podemos obviamente
nunca llegamos pensando que íbamos a
entrar en Ucrania llegamos a la frontera
Polonia Ya teníamos mucha experiencia
con refugiados
Cúcuta de Cúcuta a bucaramanga todos los
venezolanos saliendo por Colombia por
Panamá ya refugiados ya habíamos tenido
experiencia y por eso pensábamos que en
Polonia podíamos hacer un trabajo
importante es donde empezamos
pero vimos que la necesidad era
increíble eran miles y miles de personas
saliendo por un montón de puntos
diferentes no solamente a través de
Polonia pero a través de todos los otros
países que rodeaban bordean Ucrania en
menos de dos semanas ya estábamos en más
de 50 puntos con una especie de cafés
24/7 para que las madres los niños los
ancianos pudieran estar al calor de un
fuego y en tiendas para que en esa
espera muchas veces interminable de
cruzar la frontera con unos guardias
fronterizos estaban abrumados por por
esa salida de golpe de tanta gente lo
que hacíamos era que hubiera comida
caliente que hubiera bebida caliente y
sobre todo empezar a darles un poco de
cariño un montón en unas horas y unos
días que se convirtieron en horrorosos
para tanta gente pero vimos que la
necesidad iba mucho más allá a las
sensaciones de tren estaban abrumadas
las gasolineras no tenían ya comida
empezamos a entrar en Ucrania y
empezamos a hacer lo que siempre hacemos
Cuál es la forma más rápida restaurantes
y los locales empezamos a Añadir
restaurantes más de 550 que nos ayudaron
a cubrir las necesidades de la gente que
se iba Pero también la gente que se
movía del este al oeste a ciudades como
leópolis para sentirse si alguna de
alguna forma se puede decir como más a
salvo y es cuando llegamos a más de 1500
refugios que podían ir de una casa de 10
personas el de Varsovia que había miles
y miles de personas y llegamos a un
millón y medio de comidas en forma de
comida caliente y luego bolsas de comida
que repartíamos en las zonas
Rurales donde recordemos Ucrania tiene
comida lo que Ucrania necesitaba era
infraestructura y logística y crear un
equipo que tuviera una simple misión
aquellas personas que no tengan comida
bien intentando salir de Ucrania o bien
porque donde viven se han acabado los
mercados
asegurarnos de que esas personas le
íbamos a cubrir esa necesidad puntual
pero también los dimos llegar a las
zonas asediadas y bombardeadas bajo los
momentos más difíciles llevándoles
bolsas de comida a las personas que
viven allí eso es una nueva dinámica de
su organización
obviamente los locales
conocen mucho mejor el terreno si te
venía alguien de una gran ciudad y
llegaba a un kilómetro dos kilómetros
muy cercano al frente de batalla
te podías poner en riesgo por muchas
razones Minas Por irte por el camino
equivocado y acabar en frente de las
tropas rusas Entonces por supuesto que
como teníamos la infraestructura de
acercar lo más que podíamos esas bolsas
al final poco a poco íbamos
encontrandonos con líderes locales los
alcaldes de los pueblos pequeñitos gente
joven que de golpe de la Nada se
convertían en grandes líderes para su
comunidad y así es como lugar a lugar
sitio a sitio día a día Pues si vamos
entablando esas tomas de contacto con
gente maravillosa que han sido los que
han hecho realmente posible el trabajo
de bolsa entre Quiche no 2008 millones
de comidas servidas entregadas puerta a
puerta con una sonrisa y siempre con un
mensaje no que la gente lo que quiere es
su dignidad y la forma mejor de poder
darle dignidad es escucharles estar a su
lado y repito no en ese caso hay muchas
maneras de defender un país la comida es
otra forma de defenderlo han sido
Muchísimas las misiones de su
organización pero cree que esta ha sido
la más difícil y la más compleja Sí esa
ha sido obviamente quien me iba a decir
a mí que íbamos a llegar a un millón y
medio de comidas diarias en su momento
covid en Estados Unidos Fue también muy
muy grande porque llegamos a estar con
más de 3.500 restaurantes y realmente
como como covid fue algo muy bonito y
muy muy potente con cientos de
hospitales en India 97 hospitales Pero
obviamente Ucrania por muchos motivos se
convertirá A lo mejor en una antes y un
después de bolsa entre kitchen no es que
nosotros queramos ir ahora conflictos
esta ha sido un conflicto bastante
peculiar está bastante limitado Dónde
están los que han sido el agresor y los
que han sido atacados y nosotros estamos
evidentemente con la gente para que
saque la guerra acabe pues Repito no que
no no haya hambre y que la comida no sea
un problema más a los muchos que se
podrían Añadir pero sí Ucrania esa
misión como llamamos
pero cada una es especial en Turquía
Hemos llegado a 350.000 comidas al día
hemos estado haciendo 100.000 comidas al
día en Siria la gran abandonada yo he
entrado en Siria que no sé si fue
inteligente o no pero al final de la
vida no puede solucionar problemas si no
tomas algún riesgo la vida hay que
arriesgarse puedes quedarte en casa y
Mirar los eventos que pasan el mundo por
televisión
pero así los problemas no se van a
solventar se van a solventar con los
pies en el suelo y yo intento
simplemente ser uno más ir ahí ver
aprender y poner nuestro pequeño granito
de arena aunque a veces parece que es un
pones un dedo en un agujero de los miles
y miles agujeros que hay en el mundo no
pero bueno si puedes cubrir un agujero
al final cada uno hace lo que pueda y
para terminar Qué le gusta más ayudar o
cocinar
y alimentas el cuerpo y cocinas y
alimentas el espíritu Yo siempre digo
que es mesas más largas muros más bajos
y obviamente la alimentación es un
problema importante que va más allá de
del hambre que el hambre es importante
que va más allá de es un fenómeno
cultural pero a la vez es un problema si
no nos lo tomamos en serio esta guerra
es una guerra realmente que sin darnos
cuenta Va a crear una inmigración masiva
ya lo ha creado Putin ha estado a cargo
de la migración masiva que ha sucedido
en Siria Putin indirectamente también en
la gran migración que ha habido en
Venezuela Putin tiene sus manos en
muchas migraciones Y por qué emigra la
gente porque no tiene futuro y porque no
tiene comida esto es una guerra por la
alimentación del planeta los ucranianos
ya no van a vivir el jolodomor famoso de
los años 30 donde Rusia realmente hizo
que millones de ucranianos murieran por
hacer un control increíble de todo lo
que producían y donde murieron muchos
está en la memoria de muchos ucranianos
cuando hablas con ellos las personas
mayores que éramos chicos se acuerdan
todavía de aquellos momentos de horror
en los pueblos más remotos Ucrania tiene
comida ya aprendieron de aquella
elección Ucrania no va a tener problemas
de alimento quien va a tener problemas
de elementos son esos otros países en
muchas partes del mundo África y demás
que dependen del grano que sale de este
país por lo tanto esto no es solamente
una guerra por la democracia por la
libertad por la justicia también es una
guerra para alimentar la esperanza del
mundo pero también
alimentar al mundo por lo tanto esa
garantía que acabar o el 2023 2024 vamos
a ver un incremento en las migraciones
de muchos otros países que parecen muy
lejanos de esta Guerra de Ucrania pero
que tendrán efectos y consecuencias en
Europa en Estados Unidos y el mundo Será
muy diferente por lo tanto por eso hay
que apoyar a Ucrania porque es una
guerra para alimentar al mundo
Muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros en español